Oslo Amsterdam oven I don't know nothing
about your countries but I'm with the
two whitest people on flagrant right now
we're going to be out there not them
just me sh said there's a lot of Indians
and I know them so we better be
there let's sell this show out Amsterdam
I'm going to do shrooms before after the
show I probably won't be high on stage
but maybe we do them together staying
away from you though cuz I'm a
faithful man who's very in love with his
wife I don't know if we're going to keep
that in the promo or not leave it in
point is you need to buy tickets I don't
know anything else we'll find a way to
make this video engaging somehow Maybe
we do one of those painting things on
the side or something bing.com for
tickets